you get fans wanting a really specific  thing from you yeah it's a little odd so  my character on the show she has a list  of people that she wants to kill well no  she they're all justified and she has a  list and she recites the names and she's  been through a lot of trauma bit of the  backstory and it's what keeps her going  and it's what keeps her fighting even  though she's lost both of her parents so  a lot of people come up to me in the  street and they want me to recite the  names but then add their name I do yeah  oh can you speak quite quickly which  camera which cat message yeah there you  go do we have you gotten some attention  music running we did well here we go  whoo go okay off you go  Joffrey Cersei Ilyn Payne the mountain  beric Dondarrion Sarris of man  the red woman Tom Hanks  you